[Music]
thank you
hello how's everyone doing I am I am
actually super excited to be here but
I've also had very little sleep so it
might not show through but yeah thanks
for coming and thanks to Jay s coffee
you for inviting me and thanks to
everyone that has made this event really
awesome it's a super great to be here
and I wanted to kind of just take a
quick moment to say like happy
anniversary
tenth year of Jay s coffee you super
exciting but also a little bit sad since
they're gonna take a little break but
let's stay positive and be excited about
the 10th year here and and I'm really
excited to see what happens next there
are some amazing people that are
involved in this whole effort so I look
forward to seeing what they what they
bring next but also happy birthday to
node I don't know if everyone knows that
this is 10 years of node and ryan
introduced node here at JSC you in 2009
shout out to Jennifer 2009 happy belated
birthday from i oj s mm-hmm got that one
in there I couldn't find the node J s
tweet that said happy birthday so I just
went with this one so I am here to talk
to you about promises in node core the
core API is in node and what state they
are in in terms of being promised a fied
and I want to start with a little
disclaimer I will try to make as few
funds as possible actually I'm going for
zero and technically I don't think this
is a pun so if you are keeping track
mark at zero Donnie I'm Joseph II my
little Twitter handles down there but
you can barely syria to see it but if
you search you'll find me I'm an
open-source engineer I have the great
fortune of being paid to work on open
source exclusively pretty much and
technically and in the community and
it's a part of the foundation why is my
phone keep buzzing I told you leave me
alone okay that's not doing it anyway so
I'm super fortunate and it's great and I
love it I work for a lovely company
called IBM we make typewriters and we
have a we have a cloud but it's really
just someone else's computer so don't be
fooled not to be confused with how so
you know IBM this is my lovely family
[Music]
this is also my lovely family this is
what I do in my spare time
it's Pat and Stella my van lease best
piece this is what I really enjoy doing
I play in another band that's also still
in the background that's me up there as
well in the back and I occasionally play
no misfits cover band so funny story all
of this was to lead up to you know
karaoke tonight but then I realized that
was my talk is after official karaoke so
however I am always open for karaoke so
if anyone wants to go I'm here all week
for the tc39 meetings ping me on my DMS
are open let's go do karaoke all right
cool so I digress which I do often if
you know me I wanted to just quickly
share a little bit of personal context
around around promises I've worked at a
company called the New York Times a few
years ago and pretty much everywhere
I've worked for the last I mean I think
almost every job I've ever had I've kind
of done some form of developer advocacy
informally or formally and we had I
started this weekly JavaScript thing
which I do every single week largely
sourced by internal folks luckily at the
times we had so many great people like
Jeremy Ashkan s and David Nolan and Mike
Bostock and you know lots of great
people but occasionally I would have
some outside folks come in and talk to
us about cool stuff so this is in like
2012-2013 Tom Hughes croucher came in
Rebecca Murphy spike came by and my old
friend Dominik was there to you so
Tom talked about sockets and streams and
knowed what's the date on this again
yeah 2012 and so I mean you know no
buzzing for a few years it was still
pretty new pretty exciting and the
hockey-stick had not really happened yet
Rebecca came and we had common formal
discussion you know group discussion
this is one of the things she talked
about shout out to a query I mean does
anyone know a query all right
do some research it's fantastic anyway
spike came and talked to us about render
which was this really cool isomorphic
framework where you could write backbone
backbone app that would be front-end and
back-end with the same code it was kind
of revolutionary at the time was really
cool and Dominic came in to talk to us
about this little spec he was working on
and at the time there were a few
libraries that were in implementing
promises but everybody kind of had their
own flavor and so Dominic was working on
you know developing a spec that would be
something that the language could
implement and and fortunately Dominic
continues to do amazing work in the the
spec space so Thank You Dominic it was
also a great opportunity for me to say
that I wrote for the New York Times
which is pretty cool
and so I talked about you know callback
hell and in JavaScript
and how we're working on it using you
know the promises of async flow and this
looks bad but it's not actually that bad
because it's fairly like linear but when
you're nesting asynchronous flow in a
variety of ways they can get really
really really painful and hard to debug
and you know I think it was one of the
quiz questions last night you know which
of these async functions are gonna end
first and if I'm not mistaken almost
everyone got it wrong then I went to
work for a company called Behance which
was a lot of fun and there are some
really smart people there and pretty
much everything that we did there was
promise based and it kind of blew my
mind for a few weeks or months or
something but once I got the hang of it
and writing all my code using promises
almost all my code it was just a
fantastic way to control your facing
flow and you may know that Ryan was here
last year talking about regrets in node
and one of the key things he talked
about was not sticking with promises and
granted this is really early on 2009 to
2010 he removed them in February and as
he says in the talk you know maybe it's
okay that that they didn't remain and
promises because not having him and the
implementation in there allowed the
community to kind of work through what
might be the best implementation so
there were a variety of libraries like I
said before queue and RSVP that were
doing their own implementations of
promises and it allowed the community to
find the right abstraction and we can
kind of go from there and it's a it's a
good model I think that we've you know
used time and again and in JavaScript
but as he said nodes many async api's
are aging pretty badly and this is
definitely a pain point in
writing node which has a lot of callback
based API obviously they think is at the
core so one tip if you are really trying
to get your talk accepted at a
conference is to reference one of the
organizers in your talk proposal I don't
know if it worked or not but I'm here in
front of you now
so one of those references is to this
tweet and it really was kind of funny
but sad loll at node.js core modules for
still using the callback pattern I mean
this is in November and I have this bad
habit of maybe it's a good habit
actually of finding something
interesting that I would like to hear a
talk about and then submitting it
whether I know a lot about it or not but
this was really interesting to me and so
I submitted a talk about how you know
we're where we are and where we're
trying to get to you and how you may be
able to help and fortunately for me it
got accepted and so here we are so one
of the responses is miles who is super
active in the node space and a variety
of spaces a lot of miles and he shares
with us that the FS API already has an
experimental promise implementation and
this is one of the problems it's not
maybe the prettiest because we needed to
figure out how to name space essentially
promise implementations of api's but he
points this out and people are pretty
excited about it and he shares that you
know unfortunately they're only two that
were implemented at the time in late
November and it's FS and DNS and they're
experimental now there are some puns on
these slides but I did not make them so
I don't I still don't think they count
keeping zero Donny and then it was also
pointed out that there is a utility in
the framework that you can basically
wrap any callback based node API using
util that promised a five and as is
stated there it's still you know still a
little horrible but
it gets us somewhere so why why was it
taken out and then has not been like
just brought back into node and this was
something Mateo said to me a couple of
days ago at the open J's collaborator
summit which happened just before Jay s
comp is that it's an insanely hard
problem that's been there forever and
that we've never really been able to
find a great way to solve and and find
consensus on what the implementation is
for a variety of reasons so the big
problem is that promises were primarily
designed for browsers and so if you have
you know something go wrong in your
promise in a browser for a user you're
only affecting one user you know one tab
they might not even notice they may
think why is my Facebook reply not not
showing up or something and they view
the console they may see some sort of
error but it probably doesn't even
affect them that much in most cases but
if something happens on the server it
could bring the whole server down and
likely will and that affects obviously
way more than than one user right so
this is one of the big problems the
challenges that we face with promises
and node core and here's an example so
we had a session at the collab summit on
this very topic and we kind of work
through some of these these things as a
group and this is pretty basic
pseudocode but this the the some
function call will anything you know
beyond that resolve will essentially get
swallowed and so you could have code
like this and a bunch of code after that
but if your promise is resolved all of
that code is essentially its run but if
you have any errors you have like very
little I think no way of really seeing
what's going on there so your app may
come down you may have all sorts of
problems but you may never know that
that's the that's the issue
and then this is another example
essentially if you have a promise that
never resolves and the event loop
finishes all of the things that it needs
to do and you just have this promise
kind of hanging out out there you don't
really know that that that that's there
because it never resolves and it's sort
of invisible as well so essentially this
is all a debugging nightmare right but
the the great news is that there there
has been progress and things are
happening there's a zero cost async
stack traces were worshipped not that
long ago and so that that can help us
get some insight into to some of these
issues but here's another big one right
so how do you promise of animators that
don't resolve once they they may have
multiple events coming back right so
what do we do there well the and and and
you know as I said there are multiple
responses the tricky part too is that
some of the key things the key core
api's use event emitter under the hood
right so this is a daunting problem well
the good news is events not once that
one's kind of easy to solve right and
that one is is already and I can't
remember there's a PR it may have only
landed and in in core but events not on
needs needs an async iterator this talk
actually has been evolving like minute
by minute hour by hour we had the the
collapse summit
Thursday and Friday of last week and
this tweet came through yesterday
morning so I'm like continually updating
these slides so and they're also my talk
notes so if they come up and I haven't
actually implemented a slide don't don't
blame me I'm working on it but the great
news is there's a PR open by Mateo to to
implement async iterator for for the
event emitter
so stuff is happening that's really
really exciting sometimes this is thrown
up as a bit of a roadblock and I you
know obviously we do need to be
considered at considering performance
and the implementations that we're
making but I think we need to make sure
we balance them between the developer
experience and and and delivering on
what is you know a modern interface for
for a modern platform right so like I'm
kind of getting at the good news is that
things are getting better and progress
is being made on a on a very ongoing
basis some api's are already done as I
mentioned FS and DNS events not once
there there are a few others that are
already implemented some PRS are open
like the one we just looked at for a
second there I have one and I'm going to
open over the next few days that's
around crypto so things things are
definitely happening and other
development is in progress and when I
say that I mean this is from November of
that tweet about law at node core to now
there has been a real swell of activity
and especially with the the summit
session that we had like people are
focused on this when when we asked for
volunteers there were you know six or
seven people that that raised their
hands and I'm trying to think about this
too from like a something of a project
management standpoint and helping list
out the API see what state they're in
I'll be opening some issues soon to
catalog what what API is still need to
be done and we can start to really track
this at this effort in a holistic
fashion so we try to do everything in
and node out in the open you know
through issues and comments and PRS and
such and so this is a
issue in the summit's repo for the the
recent Berlin summit and so as you can
see here one of the topics that we
talked about was unhandled rejections so
when like I showed earlier if you
resolve your promise and you have a
bunch of other stuff happen and you get
exceptions you know how can we handle
that and surface these errors so that
you know where they're coming from we
have a survey that we're working through
if people are interested in
we're also it's scroll if I were able to
scroll down on the screenshot there's a
link to user feedback survey that's I've
been trying to get over the finish line
that would be more for end-users what
their experiences are how they're
managing promises and give us more
insight into what what we may want to be
considering and further development here
and then that bottom link there is a
list of all the api's and and some notes
on on the current state of things so as
I mentioned there's a survey primarily
focused for implementers as to what we
think would be the the best way to
handle these these rejections this is
that list of the api's that I mentioned
there are only 50 of them and a bunch of
them are not relevant some of them
already done but you know we're trying
to get a real handle on the overall
effort but like I said the the
groundswell within the project is real
people are focused on this it's taking a
little bit of time to get there but we
have pr's open there's there's work
being done and annex it's it's it's
actually kind of exciting to think that
we may have some more modern and
interfaces for these core api's so the
the kind of call to action here to is if
you are at all interested we always
welcome people to get involved I know
sometimes working on node core can be a
little daunting but it's it's not that
bad
you should talk to any of us folks who
are involved in it Joey before and
Federer and stuff you know any of the
folks that around here they're involved
would be happy to to share with you it
is a strategic initiative for the the
tech
steering committee the TSC matteo is the
champion I'm trying to help along with
Rubin - Rubin Bridgewater - kind of
spearhead some of these things Myles has
done some work I mean everybody's doing
work on this Benjamin is involved
there's a lot of people who are focused
on it now which is exciting this is one
of those slides that that I should have
updated but I haven't actually filed
that initiative PR yet so once I do next
to Mateos name there will be a link
right there that would be the issue that
would catalog where we are and I promise
you that we will resolve this problem
[Music]